comment vaincre le stress phénomène
préoccupant dans nos sociétés un
psychiatre david servan shreiber vient
d'écrire un livre dont le succès a été
immédiat il passe en revue un certain
nombre de thérapie du stress avant tout
nous arrêtons nous partons sur une
d'entre elles au nom barbare le mdr
destiné à soigner les traumatismes
émotionnels à la suite d'accidents de
deuil de viols d'agressions diverses
reportage dans le cabinet d'un
psychanalyste de montpellier c'est
impressionnant nathalie sapina antoni
masset vous vraiment vous pénétrez de
cette cible et dès que vous les ouvrez
je démarre le balayage une baguette
magique et la séance peut commencer
le ndr est une méthode qui soigne les
traumatismes émotionnels par les
mouvements des yeux une méthode
déroutante qui a séduit mari son
compagnon est mort il ya deux ans d'une
tumeur au cerveau et marina pas
surmonter son deuil
ce qui se traduit par des angoisses des
pleurs d'irrépressibles des insomnies
sur la technique
marie se concentre sur une scène
particulièrement pénible qu'elle a du
mal à se remémorer sans pleurer
mais au fur et à mesure marie prend du
recul
à la fin de la séance se souvenir ne lui
tire plus de larmes plus pour lui mais
j'y peux rien donc quelque chose de
changé
cette première séance a duré 45 minutes
marie reviendra deux ou trois fois
cette thérapie très brève suffit à
surmonter les traumatismes parfois vieux
de plusieurs années
loufoque c'est complètement loufoque
c'est exactement ce que j'ai pensé la
première fois en 94
quand mon ami françois volet m'a
présenté cette méthode
je n'ai vu dans aucune autre thérapie on
est pratiqué plusieurs est-ce qu'ils
soient aussi performante jamais je n'ai
vu ça le thunder existe depuis 15 ans
mais le grand public l'a découverte avec
le livre à succès de david
servan-schreiber ce psychiatre a
lui-même soigner des patients atteints
de choc psychologique
grâce à cette méthode soit des grands
traumatismes un viol un braquage dans
une banque à un accident de voiture très
grave un incendie ou des petits
traumatismes ce qu'on appelle les petits
traumatismes comme une fausse couche ou
le fait quand vous annoncez que vous
avez un cancer du sein donc pour ces
traumatismes émotionnels et leurs
conséquences on a plus de quatorze
études contrôlées qui demande que le mda
marche remarquablement perd donc c'est
pour ça que ça va prendre et que les
enfants s'en servir que mes confrères
vont servir pour l'instant aucune étude
scientifique n'explique comment une
gymnastique des yeux aide à digérer les
épreuves de la vie mais pour marie pas
de doute il y à bien un avant et un
après mdr j'ai remué un sujet qui était
douloureux
sur ce sujet là c'est sûr que j'ai été
surprise de l'apaisement que j'ai
retrouvé tout d'un coup alors que ça
faisait longtemps que j'avais pas
ressenti ça inefficace sur les
dépressions ou le mal-être diffus le mdr
est un outil de plus dans la panoplie
des thérapies de l'âme
à côté des médicaments et de la
psychanalyse